the Joe Rogan experience I mean okay I
did a I did a podcast in my living room
I was late eighteen times Porto Rican
comedians were beating me in my kitchen
yeah iiiii was late eighteen times
that's hilarious
I wouldn't have you know people are
waiting outside and I caught traffic by
the bathroom I would say rats how out of
control it was my friend Jay is one of
the producers of the doctors and they
were gonna fix your nose yeah but
they're worried that if they did it
they'd have to give you painkillers
right well that's that's a big thing to
like with the drug court thing if you
get any type of surgery they gotta do
paperwork also the guy from botched it
wants to do it too I'm actually in a
bidding war to fix my nose what happened
to it um a bunch of things 30 years of
drugs right okay you want to hear
stories first of all a bookie I was
dealing with a few years ago had a guy
who used to work for him who got this
idea to try to get money out of me and
he he sucker punch me at my this kid was
a 19 year old boxer and he can't I was
going to my car one day and he thought I
was like you saw me on TV
he thought I was like a billionaire and
I'm going to my car and I hear our day
and the kid hits me with a right hand
right I just like I mean like you can
never get off on a regular fight you
know like like the way cloisonne Trevor
Berbick right here right here right on
mine and collapse and collapse the bone
right here knock me out for 10 minutes
at least 10 minutes and and and you know
that situation got solved the way it got
solved but you know I mean well I just
had to deal with it in my own way I did
I made up with the guy through you know
intermediaries and everybody's fine and
we moved on but the kid laid me out the
kid I mean it's a 99 you guys just boom
and so that's one thing 30 years of drug
use but this is one of the crazier story
so there was this stripper I used to go
on the road with and she would meet me
in City she's actually from Boston
she was from shoes from Southie and she
was hopital but when she's like talk
during sex you sound like Mark Wahlberg
that accent so gross you wicked hot [ __ ]
you know but she was beautiful and over
the years like I would meet her at Hotel
she would call me on the road and she
was a drug addict
mr. snort drugs together so we're at a
hotel in st. Louis it's about he's got
about five years ago now no no it was
three four years ago and um we're
snorting oxy coat so to snort the pills
you gotta crush him up so we're in this
hotel room this nice hotel room I got a
show that night at a big theater and um
I go take a shower she takes out like
like about about five pills and starts
crushing them now was a nice hotel so we
had room service the room service had a
salt shaker that was glass so she
couldn't crush one of the pills she
takes she takes the salt shaker and
starts hitting the pill with it and the
salt shaker breaks glass breaks okay so
then she takes a credit card and and you
know makes it into a fine powder a fine
dust not knowing there's all glass in in
the powder she cuts out like four lines
she gets called down to the desk to go
to I bought her a gift so she goes down
to get the gift I come out of the out of
the bathroom I see the lines and I take
a I take a pen that I'd cut down and I
snort one of the lines and there's glass
in it I snorted glass and oxy coat
holy [ __ ] so it sounded like a zipper I
just like I saw one picture of your nose
where was enormous ly swollen that's
after the kid punch me
that was every point that was after the
garage pan you know he he tweeted it out
he was trying to be a jerk-off he put he
took a picture of me with my phone and
tweedle it he was he had a bad plan but
it that way to try to get money out of
me and the bookie who yeah that that was
after I got punched yeah so that got out
all over the place yeah and again that's
my life that's the chaos that was my
life but I snorted a line oxy code that
all glass
fine cut up glass
it sounded like a zipper and then my
nose just started to it just it just
went nuts it was bleedin and I went to
the hospital I got to cancel the show
and I wanted to strangle a girl and
that's what he caved in that started the
process if you watch the show crashing
you I'm on that three seasons you could
see my nose morphing into what it is now
like from a regular nose to like what it
is now and again part of me I I tell
young kids apartment want to get a fix
because every time I look in the mirror
I go this is a life that this is this is
what happened to me yeah it's a reminder
maybe to to not [ __ ] up again yeah and
maybe it tells kids that though it's
just such a dangerous thing to get it
fixed and then to be in that kind of
intense pain and then have the
temptation to take a pill the premise is
while you're in the hospital you get
what you need because you can't get it's
an operation so you think I put you out
they put you out yeah but then
afterwards look I had my deviated septum
fixed right and they gave me a couple
different painkillers that I didn't use
I got out and I was I I didn't use them
when I had knee surgery either let me
ask you see this fascinates me so as a
guy who gets obsessed with stuff right
yeah and you feel at euphoria that
morphine drip
yeah the the obsession over that feeling
is not as strong as you not wanting to
[ __ ] your life up not even close
yeah I know I know it feels great but my
brain is i okay out of here cover your
cover your hand tuck your chin
bob-and-weave get the [ __ ] out of the
corner get out of there okay here's what
here's what a drug addict is is what
this is where they claim it's a disease
I'm smart enough to realize that too but
I'd do it anyway yeah I'm the direct
opposite I never I never got into the
drugs at a young age but still you feel
that feeling yeah you know what I mean
like think like you know if that that's
something like like you know to me the
sick person is well why don't you want
to feel like that'll you know yeah it's
crazy
like some people have a painkiller
prescription all these pills in a bottle
they don't finish it I promise too much
yeah I sold mine I took percocet so I
think it was percocets when I had my
first near
operation after the morphine drip I got
out they gave me percocets I took it one
day and it was it made me so stupid okay
I've never sitting on my couch my god
I'm so dumb right now I can't think okay
I got that I I the MA I took in one day
I counted cuz I was obsessed when I took
a hundred and twenty-three percocet in
one day go to 20 feet hard so I got
pancreatitis Jesus Christ I was on the
liver list and then my liver came back
oh I guess she talked about her on the
transplant list and they were about to
put me on the list the doctor said to my
family said to my mother's sister he's
gonna need a liver this is like this is
five years ago because I got out of
control with the percocets which is why
I went back to snorting I was try not to
snore I was taking oral for your health
yeah so once that once you snort the
glass how do they get it out of your
nose well I had to go to the emergency
what does do for like four days what do
they do they cut it out they yeah they
had it they had to go in they do a
surgery they knock you out they gotta go
up and they clean and then I had surgery
again a couple of years ago to do it so
there's no like I should breathe good
and everything now I don't know you know
but again they would take a piece of rib
right do they take your cartilage from
in between your rib which will
eventually grow back and right here
would prop it up they do it the fighters
well yeah yes man the guy at the doctors
I want to see him the guy though yeah
and he was like I don't know because he
never saw he goes he never saw a worse
nosed Wow he looked in the nose because
I never saw wears no that's incredible
and graduations yeah I'm very
goal-oriented but if they did fix it you
know
the real issue would be what it feels
like when you get out of the hospital
right and you know how whether or not
that would disrupt your progress enough
the point we were absolutely back well
again I'm making more more mature
decisions now because I could have went
right into this mm-hmm but and again the
doctor had botched was was cool about it
till you said you need more clean time
at least a year yeah for you even try
yeah well good for him for thinking that
way I mean like a big episode for them
and again if I can't if I couldn't
breathe it'd be one thing but I can
breathe all right and like wow you know
I never looked like David Beckham
what do I care yeah that's gotta give
you some material on stage as well I say
stop to smell the roses in life and they
had cocaine album it it's it's it's it's
been an odyssey of craziness
[Applause]